hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt wie ihr sehen können bin ich immer
noch schwanger aber ich glaube wenn ihr
das video anschaut bin ich vielleicht
nicht mehr schwanger keiner weise ist
keine ahnung
auf jeden fall habe ich jetzt gerade
noch zwei tage bis zu meinem
entbindungstermin also bis zum 21 10 und
die ella ist immer noch nicht da und ich
habe mir gedacht komm dann aus
langeweile und ich habe es euch ja
versprochen mache ich noch mal ein
update oder es zeigt euch noch eine
klinik tasche die ich schon gepackt habe
und sagte ich einfach aktuell wie es mir
geht
also wie gesagt 40
schwangerschaftswochen und noch zwei
tage bis zum termin
und eigentlich hatte ich schon damit
gerechnet dass sie früher kommt zumal
auch mein arzt gesagt dass die kommt
bestimmt früher und zwei tage vor termin
kommt bestimmt und naja es war nur eine
vermutung aber der tag ist noch lang
beweises nicht meine familie spekuliert
auch schon jeden tag und wäre sogar eine
whatsapp gruppe das ist total wird sich
der murat freut sich da auch denn meine
schwester hat sondern whatsapp gruppe
gemacht hat jeder sein tipp abgegeben
wann die kleine kommt und im moment
verliert grad jeden tag irgendjemand und
derjenige muss beim 25 euro ins
sparschwein schmeißen total witzig
deswegen freut sich der murat klar
also mir geht es immer noch sehr gut
ich glaube dass ich auch das problem
warum sie nicht kommen will
die fühlt sich einfach pudelwohl und ich
habe mich die letzten zwei wochen
eigentlich so ziemlich entspannt wir
haben sehr viel zeit mit samira mit
murat verbracht und waren viel draußen
und es ist ja gerade so schön was heißt
schön schallt ein herbstliches wetter
aber ich finde es nicht schlimm ich
finde es eigentlich ganz schön und sie
will halt einfach nicht
und mittlerweile wird ziemlich
langweilig wie gesagt mir geht's gut ich
war letzte woche freitag beim abschluss
letzte mal habe jetzt ungefähr 18 kilo
zugenommen bisher ab schwangerschafts
beginn und mein bauch umfang weiß ich
ehrlich gesagt nicht auf jeden fall
riesig
und ich merke zwar schon ab und zu sehen
die merklich halt teilweise im rücken
oder auch im bauch einziehen und mir
wird es dann immer ganz komisch
irgendwie ich weiß nicht ob ich dann ob
dann der blutdruck abfällt keine ahnung
auf jeden fall ist es innerlich ganz
komisch aber es war halt bisher noch nie
so richtig heftig letzten freitag war es
zwar so dass wird ein abend im
krankenhaus waren weil ich gedacht okay
es geht los
aber ich glaube also murat hat auch
schon gesagt ich war einfach so
entspannt und ich hatte zwar permanent
wen aber es war halt keine geburtswehen
und die hebamme hat sich angeschaut hat
gesagt das kind die krieg ein kind
kriegt sind viel entspannter hat sich de
facto ist mein erstes kind ist es
zweiter zu können sie auch im zweiten
spiel eigentlich sicherer aber das
problem ist bei samira hatte ich ja
keine wehen sondern ich hatte ja ein
blasensprung also die fruchtblase
geplatzt
und deswegen bin ich damals ins
krankenhaus und dieses mal ich weiß
einfach nicht mehr wie stark die venen
sind vielleicht auch ganz gut aber ich
habe einfach gemerkt sie sind permanent
und hören nicht mehr auf aber man hat
doch keine geburtswehen aber lieber gehe
ich einmal zu viel als einmal zu wenig
hat sie auch gesagt lieber vorsichtig
sein aber wir durften dann wieder
heimgehen fand es ein bisschen eine
enttäuschung nach dem 2 ja tut mir leid
aber danach haben welches gut geschlafen
weil sie mir aber meine eltern war aber
dann dort abgegeben
und ja jetzt warte mal jeden tag drauf
ich trinke fleißig hinblätterte das
sieht so ein bisschen wen fördernd und
macht den muttermund bisschen weich
wirkt entspannend dann gehe ich ab und
seit die badewanne
dann laufe ich ganz viel ich gehe sogar
freiwillig zum müll runter ich hole
freiwillig die wäsche aus dem aus der
waschmaschine im keller der macht hat
schon fragt was ich schon mit dir los
aber ich will einfach endlich kommt na
ja heute schon immer ja heute packe ich
noch ein kuchen linzer torte ja auf
jeden fall
gibt's natürlich so ebenso die
natürlichen möglichkeiten ein bisschen
die wm zu fördern
aber es klingt kommt erst an wenn es
wirklich auch bereit dazu ist und
deswegen bringt auch mein ganzer
hinblättert eh nix um das ganze laufen
sie kommt einfach dann wenn sie möchte
der ingwer und zimt bringt auch nichts
ja habe ich vorhin schon getrunken
ich habe so eine kleine liste gemacht
weil ich oft vergesse was zu erwähnen na
ja auf jeden fall haben wir bisher schon
alles bereit
ich habe noch ein paar sachen die sie
noch nicht da zum beispiel eine kleine
badewanne aber musée de la oder ein baby
nicht gleich baden deswegen ist es nicht
schlimm
das wichtigste was bereit sein sollte
wenn er so kurz vor der geburt steht ist
dass er einfach im bett hat für das baby
da habe ich so ein beispiel bett was man
direkt ins bett mit einklemmen kann ich
habe ihre klamotten die habe ich von
samira noch habe ich neulich alle aus
dem keller gekramt und gewaschen
ich habe windeln da und wir da ich sie
stillen möchte braucht mich ja kein
futter sondern als er dann bei mir also
das ist mein koffer
ich wollte eigentlich in kleineren
wahlen weiter nur ein paar tage im
krankenhaus wobei man es nicht weiß also
wenn irgendwie komplikationen auftreten
ist man vielleicht auch länger drin
deswegen es hat aber nix in einen
kleineren profilpass weg halt da hier
auf jeden fall habe ich einen blog mit
dabei falls ich mir was auf schreiben
will und tempos und wobei ich hier mal
alles ins handy notiere aber egal ist
trotzdem über mit eingepackt habe ich
schon unterwäsche und still bhs auf
jeden fall
und dann
brauchen wir natürlich ein paar
gemütliche klamotten weil es ist nicht
so dass ihr ein baby bekommt und danach
richtet auch wieder weg und ihr seht
wieder auch sie vorher sondern ihr habt
einfach dann noch im bauch weil sich die
gebärmutter erstmal wieder zurückziehen
muss das heißt man sieht dann ungefähr
aus wieso im sechsten monat schwanger
heute hatte ich auch schon so ein riesen
braucht na ja auf jeden fall habe ich
halt da ein paar tops auch ein paar
stopps diesen ganz praktisch weil ich
das eigentlich ganz gerne mag wenig halt
so ein top an hab so wie jetzt und dann
einfach so eine weste drüber
deswegen sind die mit dabei und da habe
ich so vier stücken etwa dabei weil bei
mir war es zum beispiel so beim letzten
mal
ich hatte halt nach der geburt durch die
hormonumstellung immer mir war es immer
viel zu warm und dann hatte ich lieber
sohn zwiebel look an also immer
irgendwas drüber und zum drüber anziehen
habe ich dann einfach so ein paar
bequeme police so eine jacke die demo
rat nicht mag was er immer sagt ich sehe
damit aus wie cindy von marzahn sind die
ausmaß haben das ist halt mit
reißverschluss finde ich dann auch
praktisch und ich finds halt bequem wege
geht es auch mit und noch so eine
schwarze weste so wie ich jetzt halt an
habe weil ja als auch praktisch ist so
dann habe ich noch ein paar bequeme t
shirts das sind auch still t shirts mit
dabei das wusste ich am anfang da hat
das ist in t shirts sind aber ich glaube
ich habe mir mal als am anfang der
schwangerschaft haben sie noch gepasst
jetzt passen sie nett aber ich denke
wenn der bauch so ein bisschen kleiner
ich passen sie wieder
deswegen nehme ich die noch mit dann für
nachts habe ich halt nachthemden und
pyjamas
da habe ich auch stille nacht hätten
dabei die halt vorne so knöpfe haben
dass ich dann eben auch ganz praktisch
jeder und das wetter schon voll deswegen
berghofer dann habe ich es gibt zwar
haben bücher im krankenhaus aber ich
habe gern fürs gesicht meiner eigenen
deswegen nehme ich so drei gesichtern
tücher und waschlappen mit ich weiß da
habe ich über
über die eigenen dann habe ich zwei
lange leggings schwangerschafts leggings
diesen ganz bequem und eine jogginghose
dass auch die die schwangerschaft sie
mal an hatte
und wenn ich ins krankenhaus farbigen
geruhsam ich glaube so diese jeanshose
und dann habe ich auch was was ich
danach eben zur heimat wieder anziehen
kann
und dann habe ich hier noch ein kleid
und zwar ist es auch ein still kleid und
das ist total bequem hatte ich jetzt
auch in der schwangerschaft total gerne
an und deswegen nehme ich das auch mal
mit falls ich das einfach auf dem
heimweg dann ansehen will mit einer
strumpfhose so murat denkt sich gott
sieht die aus oder jahre sich halt es
war wirklich so letztes mal ich hab halt
echt permanent geschwitzt und muss mich
halt jeden tag zweimal umziehen und ja
deswegen ein paar sachen mehr da
natürlich socken und vor allem warme
socken vor allem für die geburt habe ich
gelesen dass ist durch das kalte füße
die wehen hemmen
das heißt bei der geburt braucht die
warme füße also warme kuschel socken
monats grauen 100 km
so das war's eigentlich so an klamotten
was ich mitnehme wahnsinn meine mutter
bin nur eine typische wirklich ist ohne
spaß die hatten eher die kühlen also
öffentlichen verkehrsmittel sind dann
zur entwicklung gefahren seid nett weg
ist im bus noch wissen meine mutter ich
100 prozent im bus zur entbindung
gefahren
sie hatte einen jahreszuschuss werden
keine harten karotte günstiger so ist es
das war es jetzt so zu den klamotten
dann zu den kosmetikartikel oder was
heißt kosmetik er so hygiene und was
sagt man da drogerie produkte weil ich
mal nah krankenhaus zum entbinden mal
bekommt ein kind
und da ich eigentlich bisschen
zweitrangig aussehen und vor allem ich
weiß es zum letzten mal noch da hatte
ich noch meine hab mal gesagt ja ich
packe meine schminkt sachen mit ein und
alles mit und setzt du wirst dich mit
hundertprozentiger sicherheit net
schmecken im krankenhaus und ich hab es
mir echt nicht vorstellen können aber
ich hab echt nett gemacht
weil man macht ja auch meistens ein
fotoshooting und geschminkt sich nicht
wirklich ich habe meine haare geföhnt
ich hab so gekämpft
ja da drin das ist amiras tage übrigens
habe ich einfach shampoo und körpercreme
und dod ist ganz wichtig das ging mir
letztes mal aus da muss man eine
freundin meter noch einzeln bringen dann
die normalen sachen wie carmen
lippenbalsam weil ich jetzt vor allem im
herbst und winter halt oft trockene
lippen bekommen und zahnbürste noch
meine schwangerschaft tabletten also die
vitamine die man nimmt ihr nämlich dort
dann auch noch weiterhin und öl für mein
bauch und für meinen körper und es war
es eigentlich zahnpasta ist natürlich
klar und der stecker für meine
zahnbürste und was ich immer damals
gerne habe haargummis in allen
variationen weil ich hab sie einfach
gern zu und daher habe ich die noch und
hier habe ich so ein bisschen kosmetik
ich weiß ich brauche aber ich möchte man
mit aber ich rechne trocken
ich glaube und die wichtige ockert dass
ich die allerwichtigsten taschen hat
zwar schon gelacht und meine mama aber
ich habe noch eine tasche und hab ich da
lacht jetzt aber ich habe meine äpfel
drin royal gala weil ich die so gern es
und dann habe ich noch ein paar getränke
drin und tomatensaft und müsliriegel
weil lokale gesehen hast du noch nicht
gesehen und opa bonbons weil ja ich weiß
noch beim letzten mal da ich mein man
kriegt ja essen im krankenhaus aber so
als zwischen snack krieg ich halt oft
hunger deswegen ist es zeit gerne äpfel
und somit müsli und getränke hat noch
keinem geschadet außerdem habe ich ja
dabei an sich gedacht kann er sein juwel
unserer zuge kann es sein dass du werden
der geburt hunger krieg schon solche
höhen ab
weder die stadt familien döner holen ab
und zu essen aber egal
ja auf jeden fall habe ich dir jetzt
eingepackt das wichtigste natürlich ist
was ihr dabei haben sollte teuer
mutterpass aber den habe ich immer in
meiner handtasche von daher ist er
automatisch immer mit dabei
den braucht ihr auf jeden fall zur
geburt weil da einfach alles drinsteht
was in eurer schwangerschaft halt vor
gefallen so und dann meine klinik tasche
monats klinik tasche ach so ganz kurz
noch ich habe natürlich auch das habe
ich letztes mal vergessen
ich hatte beim letzten mal nicht dran
gedacht dass ich eine wickeltasche
mitnehmen muss und habe nicht dran
gedacht dass mein kind anziehsachen
braucht wer ins heim geht es war ganz
blöde hat nichts mit gepackt und hat
meine mama klamotten für die sanierer
mitgegeben
und die habe ich jetzt in meiner
wickeltasche und hab da einfach noch ein
paar windeln mit drin und das war's
deswegen hat nämlich die noch mit und
jetzt hat der rat noch eine wickeltasche
schon eine klinik tasche und ich weiß
was ich eingepackt hat ich habe
eigentlich gedacht wollen mutig muss
damit ich muss damit ja ich habe
eigentlich gedacht dass es reicht wenn
das sich snacks mitnimmt aber natürlich
ist auch weg das muss man muss ja man
sagen was was hier solche in diesem
krankenhaus haben wir diesmal gar keine
zeitschriften wenn ich mal ein bisschen
drauf warten muss im letzten krankenhaus
in waren anderes krankenhaus da waren
zeit ruhig gelesen aber bei der
anmeldung jetzt gesehen genau und jetzt
war natürlich keine zeit zeitschrift
jetzt gucken was dieser eingepackt ab
service pack 1 also meine tasche kann zu
mouras klinik tasche ich weiß nicht was
angepackt hat ich bin gespannt
ok also die zeitschriften
glaubst du wirklich dass du so lange
warten alles eingepackt ok zeitschriften
hat das ich eingepackt genau
irgendwie stimmt die tasche aber was
soll's murat a
ich finde es super lieber nen apfel
ich habe auch ein neutralisiere
eingepackt natürlich bei den schlüssel
brauchst du bist erst kommendes jahr
nach draußen geht es wieder zurück
das ist ganz praktisch kamera wäre zwar
eine speicherkarte im rheinpark
taschentücher dass man weiß was auf
putzen muss unter stärken getränke
eingepackt
na ja das ist es das ist der starbucks
der türken aber du bescheid mittel
egoistisch ich habe von allem immer
mehrere mitgenommen und nimmt sich nur
eine dose mit genau ist alles drin
die zwei sachen ja das sind zwei
umschläge datum eintragen ich muss es
noch diesen monat schaffen
es geht dieses mal noch kommt dann
bekomme für nächsten mal schon geld
auswahl war das ist wichtig in einem
umschlag geld von schwiegereltern genau
die tun dann das cambridge die hater
damit mache ich mir aber natürlich
gleich ein bausparvertrag oder irgendwas
man merkt einfach dinosaurs an so was
müssen sie auch gleich der ja natürlich
also moratz klinik tasche hätte man dann
auch schon wir
die at t shirt bequeme schuhe an bequeme
klamotten genau weiß keiner wirklich
lang an kurz gehen bereits geändert und
ich packte er das gleich wieder ein aber
das triple pack in den kühlschrank also
es geht darin lask installieren was ich
habe natürlich auch noch bequeme schuhe
dabei
da nehme ich meine crocs mit weil im
krankenhaus harald crocs an oder halt
hausschuhe auf jeden fall
und was ja auf jeden fall auch mitnehmen
sollten
er ist ein autositz stations bei uns
schon im auto als hat die babyschale
weil ansonsten könnte er das baby gar
nicht nach hause bringen außer ist
natürlich mit den öffentlichen
verkehrsmitteln nach hause also ist es
meine mutter gelegt und dafür habe ich
dann einfach noch so sonst sagt fischer
draußen ziemlich kalt das einfach den
baby nicht kalt wird habe ich auch noch
von samira und das wichtigste eigentlich
hatte ja auch gesagt dass wir für samira
was dabei haben weil wir dann eben nach
hause kommen also nicht als wenn wir
dann nach hause kommen dass eben die
samira ja auch so ein bisschen was von
ihrer schwester hat sie bekommt dann ein
kleines geschenk und es tut einfach den
kofferraum und wenn wir dann mit der
kleinen er nach hause kommen hat aldi
samira auch was eine kleine
aufmerksamkeit bekommt wenn die ela
kommt angela erreichen geschenk mit
und da habe ich alles gesagt was wünscht
du dir denn hatte seinen bauch
geflüstert und wenn sie es so leise wie
viel staat musste immer sagen gemacht
lautes und schwarz ist und sie hat mich
halt knete gewünscht und jetzt haben wir
knete geholt mit so einem kleinen set
also wirklich nur eine kleinigkeit und
es bekommt sie dann einfach so als
aufmerksamkeit und ja ich denke dass man
dann so ganz gut damit umgehen können
die noch nicht sagte jetzt wann kommen
wir nicht wieder papa vielleicht fragt
sich deswegen wie gesagt immer wann
kommt endlich die airline nicht endlich
mit ihr kuscheln echt süß
ja und ansonsten so zum
krankenhausaufenthalt vielleicht bei uns
in der türkischen kultur sag ich jetzt
mal ist ganz üblich dass man immer mega
viel besuch bekommt im krankenhaus weil
aber jetzt irgendwie weil die leute
neugierig sind oder irgendwie der böses
wollen die denken einfach kommen ist er
was gutes und besucher sie dann halt und
dann nehme dir halt die komplette
verwandtschaft mit als ich weiß noch
besser mehr
ich hatte am zweiten tag ich glaube 20
leute da und dass ich einfach viel zu
viel vor allem für die mama für das baby
und ich glaube wenn er selber freunde
habt oder wenn ihr selber schwanger sei
dann wie es dir einfach dass man so
gerade die ersten tage im krankenhaus
und zu hause sind bis in seine ruhe
braucht und
freunde und familie die verstehen ist
natürlich auch die frage soll ich kommen
und wenn man dann satte komfort bei mir
geht's gut dann geht einfach hin und
wenn man sagt du mir geht es nicht so
gut mir das lieber du kommst nach hause
dann sollte man das eben auch
akzeptieren und verstehen
vor allem ist es ja auch für sein baby
ganz anstrengend sondern geburt ist eine
lange reise für die mama es anstrengend
man muss sich ja zuerst selber mal so an
das familienleben gewöhnen
für die fahrer ist anstrengend sein
vater ist anstrengend deswegen darf man
auch keinem böse sein der dann irgendwie
sagt nee ich möchte lieber meine ruhe im
krankenhaus und ja ich habe jetzt auch
aktuell ganz viele freundinnen die
schwanger sind und die mich dann auch
fragen sollen wir kommen oder sollen wir
lieber nach hause kommen und ich habe
dann einfach sagt du klar du kannst
gerne kommen und aber sag einfach auch
bescheid wenn wenn es eben nicht geht
also ich verstehe das auch total wenn es
jemand nicht will dann ist natürlich oft
immer die frage was schenkt man denn
jemanden der gerade ein kind bekommen
hat
es ist natürlich klar dass man so ein
bisschen so die freude hat und natürlich
was kaufen möchte und alles ist süßen
baby format also man möchte gern
klamotten kaufen schuhe kaufen keine
ahnung alles mögliche kaufen spielzeug
kaufen
aber im prinzip brauchen frischgebackene
eltern wirklich nichts am besten schenk
mal wirklich geld oder gutschein weil
die wissen ja selber was sie brauchen
und sie ja selber auch so ein bisserl
gestern
man will ja auch selber mal was holen
oder man hat schon alles wie zum
beispiel haben von samira einfach schon
fast alles und wenn es nicht kaputt war
oder so und deswegen brauchen wir da nix
und ein kind brauche keine zehn
kuscheltiere und 20 strampler von daher
haben wir haben mich immer was geschenkt
bekommen als wenn wir geld das sag ich
immer auf sparbuch von den kindern
ich finde sie wichtiger als dauernd
spielzeugen oder irgendwelche sachen das
was das werden meisten eltern auch
beschädigen können die kinder spielen
allerdings mit kartons hatte stimmt bei
samira wir dürfen also eigentlich egal
was er bekommt der kann natürlich nichts
dagegen gegen aktienfonds von der
volkswagen gruppe momentan um keller
sehen
das ist kein problem
ja aber wenn man gerade dabei sind
werden wir wieder ganz coole sachen
gekriegt zwar auch wieder echt süß von
euch vor allem selbst gemachter sachen
finde ich halt total schön aber nehmt
euch doch mal die zeit für uns macht
doch was anderes als ich finde es immer
dringender
nicht alle wir haben wirklich alles was
wir nicht haben brauchen wir nicht oder
ja auch nicht alles aber sich trotzdem
zuckersüß deswegen würde ich sagen dass
trotzdem gleich einen umschlag dabei den
darf ich leider erst öffnen wenn allah
geschlüpft ist von daher weiß ich nicht
was drin ist
aber was ich halt total süß fand es so
was halt auch sachen dass das steckt
ganz viel wert dahinter also sowas
selbst genähtes wieder ein spiel total
süß hier die passende mütze für samira
hat noch nie so aus bekommen voll schild
hier die passende mit dafür sieht aus
wie spruch aber für babys sind so hoch
sind wirklich cool
die sind einfach bequem und die kann man
auf die strumpfhosen anziehen da steht
auch das ist auch selbst gemacht ja ich
verlinke ich das einfach in der infobox
ich finde sowieso ganz schön ich mag es
mit dieser wandler shops ganz gerne weil
es wirklich alles haus handgemacht ist
und ich liebe einfach diese
handwerkskunst und ich finde sowas muss
man auf jeden fall unterstützen
deswegen schreibe ich euch immerhin die
infobox rhein von wem ich das bekommen
habt weil die meisten von denen haben
eben auch ihre dawanda shops und ich
finde es einfach schön wenn man sich
handwerklich betätigt also viel schöner
als floß zu gehen und etwas zu kaufen
guck dir mal den gärten ja was alles
handmade acht stunden verbringen oder
und diese decke ist auch der absolute
wahnsinn war angeregt in sie überlegt
man jetzt wirklich 345 oder vielleicht
zwei drei wochen an den finger gewickelt
an der richtig schön und das für uns ist
es wenn es nur für mich wäre aber das
nächste von valentina gewesen sieht mich
gar nicht gehört aber egal
machen wir weiter unterstütze nichts
habe ich gesagt silly verkehr und das
hier war übrigens von myra voll süß und
hier habe ich zum beispiel die
buchstaben bekommen und zwar einmal den
schriftzug samira und einmal den
schriftsteller das zeige ich euch auch
gleich noch eingeblendet und da was aber
was für mich dabei locken
na ja auf jeden fall wieder ganz viele
tolle sachen
herzlichen dank dafür bisschen legt sich
alle wunderschön und die krabbeldecke
die werde ich jetzt auf jeden fall
benutzen und gleich in ihren in ihr
laufgitter legen und dann ist es auch
bereit wenn wir wieder vom krankenhaus
da sind und ich hoffe jetzt einfach das
wirklich schnell rät dass sie bald kommt
wir können es kaum erwarten
mir geht es einfach total langweilig und
bitte nix mehr schicken ja bitte außer
ist an michaels zu essen wird spaß
nein spaß ja das war es jetzt eigentlich
also das war denke ich offiziell mein
letztes schwangerschafts update meine
vierziger jetzt kann's losgehen oder so
langsam wird sich ungeduldig naja ich
halte euch auf dem laufenden
auf jeden fall auf instagram und auf
facebook postet ich gerne bilder und da
könnt ihr immer wieder reinschauen
da gibt's dann aktuelle ich habe jetzt
auch bei twitter angemeldet aber ich
weiß nicht ich bin nicht so wahr mir
durch alles haben snap chat
ich bleib bei instagram und facebook
kommentiert alles klar
dann wünsche ich euch noch einen ganz
schönen tag und ich hoffe ich komme bald
ins krankenhaus